hello everyone I hope we're all having a
great Saturday and if not this game will
surely improve it the game was played in
1969 it was played between the Dutch
feed a master Jonathan barley and
another Dutch player you've piqued it if
that is how it's pronounced now I'm not
sure what title mr. piket has but I'm
pretty sure it was a candidate master
but just a year before this game was
played in 1968 mr. Jonathan barley
defeated young teaming with the black
pieces so definitely quite a guy
but in this game he has the white pieces
John plays d4 and I believe this game
will be interesting especially for those
of you who enjoy the benoni either
playing it or playing against it I think
it'll be much more enjoyable for those
of you who would like to know how to
play against it but for those of you who
enjoy playing it we'll know what to look
out for so nice to have 6 C 4 C 5 D 5
and we have E 5 the Czech Benoni not
going for a 6 like in the regular Benoni
so e5 and white responds sorry white
responds with Knight to c3 capturing the
Pampas on with the D captures and e6
after F captures on e6 this is
completely fine for black black is even
better here after something like Knight
to c3 black gets to push d5 and he has
this very nice center here so after E 5
we have Knight to c3 d6 Maui for Bishop
to e7 Knight to f3 black castles and we
have h3 now I did play some of the Czech
Pannonian usually I go g6 night to h5
and then Knight to g7 but in this game
black plays Knight to e7 night we ate
probably because why play this h3 move
so Knight to h5 doesn't seem that
appealing probably because white has
this option of kicking it away with g4
but ok why does play g4 and we have
Knight to d7
Bishop to d3 now g6 practically inviting
the whites to play Bishop to h6 which he
does and now Knight to g7 which was the
whole idea of the night e8 move Queen to
d2 getting more help to this Bishop on
h6
we have 90 to f6 white castles Queen
side and King to h8 making room for this
night on g8 to be able to attack the
bishop on h6 rook D to G 1 we have
Knight to g8 attacking the bishop now h4
Knight captures Bishop Queen captures
Bishop and now f6 and well the screen is
pretty dangerous if white manages to
somehow push h5 and open up the H file
this will be completely lost for black
but it's not that easy to do so if white
were if white were to push h5 at any
given moment black will simply push g5
and good luck getting your Queen
somewhere from h6 it's not gonna be very
easy after f6 a white plate Bishop to e2
and we have rook to f7 and here a white
made a very interesting decision it's
not like I said it's not that easy to
continue this attack you can't really
push h v g5 will it will be met with g5
and probably what you would want to do
is play something like king to be 1 as
long as your king is on c1 you always
have to calculate what happens if I move
this H bounine this bishop somehow comes
to g5 forking my pinning my sorry
forking my king and the Queen but here
white made a very interesting decision
he voluntarily played the g5 and he
traps his own Queen on h6 and but
immediately wants to take advantage of
this he plays Knight to f5 sacrifices
the night but what Bishop to f8 is
coming and the Queen is trapped but this
is a well what White was actually going
for he plays he captures on f5 I will
have Bishop to f8 trapping the Queen and
now F captures and g6 would an attack on
the rook
so of course Bishop captures an h6 this
was black
idea G captures on f7 grabbing the rook
and now this bishop is still attacked on
h6 we have Bishop to g7 and now h5 now
probably a better idea was to play
something like Knights to d2 and get
this light square Bishop to h5 to help
support this pawn on f7 but mr. Barlow's
idea is also quite good
h5 we have F captors and g5 and now h6
kicking that bishop away Bishop to f6
and now Knight to e4 adding more
pressure to this g5 pawn bishop to f5
developing the bishop and also it will
be very useful guarding Jesus guarding
g6 guarding h7 also may be used in some
variations as an attacking piece white
plays Knight F captures on g5 and here
black plays Queen to e7 you don't want
to play any moves you know to remove
some attackers with Bishop captures on
e4 or Bishop captures on g5 because if
this night ever moves then rook to g8
with Czech will win back the Queen so
black doesn't want to allow any any of
the tactics he plays Queen to e7
we have rook to g3 and white is now
preparing to double up rooks on the G
file Bishop captures on g5 and Knight
captures and g5 and here probably the
best move for for black would be Bishop
to g6 at the immediately close of the G
file as this is definitely White's plan
but what doesn't really see the danger
that that is coming
he plays efore making room for the Queen
to enter the position Bishop to h5 now
guarding g6 also adding protection to
the f7 pawn we have Queen to f6 now
white plays Bishop to the bishop to d1
to add some defense if with black
manages to infiltrate his position black
plays Queen to d4 now threatening Queen
captures on c4 with check
but white doesn't mind he simply plays
rook H to g1 he doubles up on the G file
and he says Queen captures on c4 is
nothing black doesn't believe him and he
plays the Queen captures on c4 with the
check again
Bishop to g6 would be would definitely
be the move to play I mean you don't
want to allow I mean double rook son on
an open G file but you place Quinta c4
okay this is what tempo check
we have Bishop to c2 and now this was
blacks last opportunity to hang on D in
this game with a move like Bishop to g6
this move could have been played for the
last five moves but black simply refuses
to see the danger and he plays III he
says you have you got nothing I'm gonna
play Queen captures on c2 checkmate you
can't defend this but I I welcome you to
try and find the danger can you see how
white wins this game I'm gonna give you
a couple of seconds if any we want you
can even stop the video and trying to
find the winning move or the winning
variation okay so those of you who found
it congratulations it's it's but a nifty
move and for those of you who just want
to see what mr. barley had planned he
played a pawn to f8 with Queen and check
also he could have gotten the roof
doesn't really matter so rook captures
Queen so he sacrifices the second Queen
and mount Knight to f7 check as this
pawn was really in the Knights way so
that's why he says he promoted it into
Queen and sacrificed it and in this
position mr. Piggot resigned the game
the king has nowhere to go only movies
rook captures Knight and f7 and after
that we have rook to g8 with checkmate
so yeah definitely a nice game from the
Dutch feed a master John Van barley I do
hope you enjoyed this game as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon and sorry this video today
was uploaded a bit late I was at a
wedding as a second cameraman so I
couldn't really upload it any sooner see
you soon